[Music]
an artificial riding news Oh knitted by
do it for the bit do it for the babe
what the [ __ ] does that mean
Steve saying yeah like keep saying the
comedy babe I'm not saying it's he
always says it though oh yeah yeah it's
his thing with the magician life Nicky
no I refuse I love its complement he's
not here if everyone says something and
then he splinters off and he says it
even though everyone over here says it
it is not his thing yeah volcano guys
always argue about no no it's just that
she can never compliment compliment it
has to be genuine
yeah a wife's duties yeah she said his
balls are the biggest thing she's that
Percy she said in disgust but anyway ISM
would be like hey bud
that's a Steve is oh that is this cat
was saying something Bubba yeah that's a
Steve ISM I'm [ __ ] up words on purpose
yes miss Cueto's miss quite OHS what did
he get you on what was that word it was
someone's name yes even hockey yeah yeah
maybe Hawking this is not Hawking what
is it Stephen Hopkins it's just hot
walking oh I just wish it thought is
always been Stephen Hawking no but he
said it right before you did that's why
it seemed like he incepted you his laugh
is pretty contagious I started picking
up on his laugh yeah and his delivery is
a hotel he'll say a joke in the laugh at
his own joke mid joke but without that
kind of laugh and that's his delivery so
that's a Steve ISM but I will not give
him I do it for the bid go up haven
Hopkin there's no s
there was a video and you said the exact
same thing he's like you [ __ ]
you got me he was laughing the recent
announcement of an AI that can produce
plausible news stories and fiction has
writers concern
Johnny fake news mofo there is but now
they don't even need a human to write it
what I think is like they're just trying
to shift blame over two different things
like if they shift the blame over to
robots for doing operations you know no
human is accountable
yeah we're driving now that's like
that's like when you fart and you blame
it on a dog
yes exactly even on a robot robot there
are robots
that that had that can do like they can
write whole fiction stories and they can
write yeah and they know how to put
things together into sentences they're
legit sentences because Google Translate
still isn't work that yeah yeah they
haven't released any of this technology
to the public because they're worried
about it being used for the wrong
reasons well why make it say you fix for
text because it could improve it's like
why I make a laser it could be dangerous
but it could also play CDs and it could
you know juice electrician maybe yeah
repair I say well what is the point of
the text having it right tech Oh having
it right text um well I mean like you'd
be faster than having a person
reauthorization and yeah it would
basically newspapers could put out stuff
faster like it could get the news out to
you faster they're probably less and
grammatical errors
yeah cuz Google always thinks it knows
what I'm gonna say when I'm typing out
an email
it doesn't know me at all like yeah I
want to say [ __ ] not ducking yeah
well it's not even that like you're
right like what you put on this is like
hey man what I really think is this
might be really and then it fills out
six words you must be new here it's to
protect my eyes from the [ __ ]
there's a lot of lights and there's a
lot of [ __ ] and a lot of haters out
there blocking them I'm protecting it so
right now the novelist's aren't fearing
too much because it's just it's in its
baby form and people have been thinking
that AI it was going to be the next big
thing for a long time but so far no real
artificial intelligence actually exists
with the capabilities but do you know
what happens exponentially right like
it's don't you want to be lazy
thought now it may
be like next year it's a full-blown yeah
have you seen the movie her what if we
program a ice to be us like I put my DNA
and then we just have JK news well see
that's why I don't give the government
my DNA with 23 of media but you don't
want to be lazy is what I'm saying I'll
be lazy people go oh I wish I could kill
myself
yeah just happy right here and then you
know what I'll be fishing I'll be doing
other [ __ ] and there's other Joe is
playing weird instruments here because
what will we do it's no extension of me
yeah and then people still be Anna doing
one day if there's if you're sitting
here and you're playing an instrument
and every notice right I know that's the
club and then you know what your clothes
gonna do cuz you're so [ __ ] smart and
stuff the clones gonna be like that's
not the that's not the real just the
clone Jon he's doing bad stuff kill that
guy oh I'm just gonna try to take me
over yes I'd like to see them try dude
the moment I played every single [ __ ]
note right yeah I'm gonna have to start
choking this fake out where the [ __ ] is
the real joke but what if I just
practiced David I just practice that's
what the clone was saying what do you
guys like the khlo better than me and
you guys keep the clone hmm what if we
can't tell the difference between you
and the clone and we and we're like you
can't you the the clone will not be able
to practice crazy though cuz that's
there's no predictable algorithm it has
his DNA it has his DNA random machine in
there that's scary you still want that
job yeah I'm a gambler you know that
[ __ ] I can go fishing I haven't been
fishing in like to go fishing all of
this you just took an eight-mile [ __ ]
walk or hike or whatever you could have
gone fishing in that time dude you know
what clothes can't do they don't have
memory oh if I test them you sure about
what happened back in 2008 cuz they're
gonna make them based on Joe now that's
true the clothes not unless they figure
out a way to transfer consciously sat
down and watch all the vlogs and
everything and read all the articles but
they wouldn't know the things that
aren't online or like the 2004 ship or
2005 [ __ ] and they might recite some of
the things that I said for fun as fact
yeah yeah well yeah right now what it
does is it doesn't really have an
intelligence it's just that it uses
statistical analysis trained on huge
amounts of human written text so it
downloads like or do you gigabytes of
webpages and in this case like they'll
receive recommendations from reddit
users too and it tries to predict what
ought to come next so it's okay but it's
not it's not like it could be really
good but not like intelligent enough to
yeah okay leave it like that let's just
have it be fun it's like oh that silly
robots never though an AI is gonna you
know advance into being able to think
for themselves
oh what if they did all the farming all
the stuff he's still on how [ __ ] up
would that be that finally you get your
clone and then that's like a second
later you're driving home and you just
get like paralyzed why I'm saying that
could happen then implant my brain in
that clone you saw the problem man I
like technology what he can do for like
the human body right so like say like I
don't know like some shitty joke I
always fix your body through things I
don't do it I really do like I would
like them to fix my knees or I could
just jump so high that's cool that'd be
awesome
like I'm just I just want robot slaves
is that too much to ask
it's like solution robot slave you're
saying yeah play whatever music I want
and she can tell me my Alexa yeah I have
both I have Google home upstairs and
then Alexa downstairs we get one of
those at our new place
no I already gave them my DNA I'm not
gonna give you what if they what if you
had Alexia that now but that's right
like what Alexia does is she understands
all your favorite foods she gets it done
by a certain time she does all the jobs
of a house house nanny
but she only needs a closet to recharge
him I would like that so that's like a
slave right but but it's not a slave
it's like a computer vacuum isn't a
slave exactly although when I'm doing my
cooking videos I call my blender my
slave and I call my slow cooker my slave
and I call all my kitchen if I remember
all that [ __ ] future I mean would you
want to do that [ __ ] that they do this I
fight the Netflix shows what's it called
where they could take your existence in
a disk and put it to another spine or
what alter carbonyl carbon yeah
how would that be kind of cool take me
up let me see what it feels like to be
whacked for it it's like you get in a
new body - you know it's like yeah I
want to know what it's like to have
Katie's that's nice kick me out here you
know do the VR that we're gonna put me
at a dog you know the VR experience that
we got you seems like pretty real
that was pretty the article this is
touching more on like these authors and
these editors are feeling threatened
their job for their job that's what you
get for shitty articles right now
they're kind of like whatever about it
they're like it's not gonna replace us
cuz because right now they have it
mastered it yeah you'll probably die by
but they're just they're just kind of
touching on how this could become yeah
it's a problem for them just like the
truck driving industry the automated
truck drivers or not truck drivers but
the machines we're gonna drive the
self-driving cars oh I can't wait for
that yeah well that industry if that
ever happens which probably is gonna
happen they're gone their their job
security is gone
right because automated or auto driving
car never has to stop to rest never only
time in these drive over life yeah 24
hours a day
only time it needs to stop is to fill up
or a tune-up you know what do you think
what do you think the people with that
how to put the [ __ ] cake mix in a
cupcake felt like one time machine came
you know like now
I love where's it going with this it's
like oh no they put the machine yeah
what are we gonna do but it's it's like
Darwinism right evolve or die you know
if you know that it's coming in the you
know it's imminent that it's gonna wait
to their self automated cars dude
[ __ ] game over that's what I'm saying
what would you do I would knock out oh
not the [ __ ] out man and I would always
be on time you won't cuz it's been a
while you'll miss your cuz you're gonna
leave the house at the wrong yeah that
would be completely okay template on
traffic idiot so what's really people
need to automate your bed so that
[ __ ] rolls you out and throws
you into the car and then the car
catches your ass and dresses you as
you're going to while a down into the
slide right into the car cuz I feel like
a half thinking of [ __ ] in there right
let's go haha get it I get it whatever I
get it whatever
[Music]